it's another serious claim from megan
about how she felt she was treated
because of her race it's only once i
started dating my husband then i started
to understand what it was like to be
treated like a black woman because up
until then i had been treated like a
mixed woman and things really shifted
the latest coming in her new podcast
series in a week where she has clearly
wanted to speak out
yesterday the cut magazine published
this interview in which megan claimed
she didn't want to share photos of her
son archie with the uk media because
they called him the n-word saying harry
lost his father in the process of them
stepping away from royal duties and
claiming one of the reasons they left
the uk was so they didn't have 40 people
snapping photos of their son every day
he went to school
papers on both sides of the atlantic
haven't exactly been sympathetic but she
does have passionate supporters
i think we need to stop telling women
what to do what to say how to express
themselves to stop overthinking and
trying to um you know police tone
strong ambitious women being ambitious
is not wrong this is exactly what meghan
markle was talking about
the problem for megan are the
inaccuracies only two cameras are
allowed when the cambridge children
start school not 40.
and some have taken offense at her
anecdote where she recalls how a member
of the lion king cast compared her
marrying harry to the excitement around
the release of nelson mandela
alyssa rosenberg wrote an article for
the washington post about why the couple
have got to leave the past behind
the dangers of using
bad experiences as the core product that
she has to offer and that i think both
of them has to offer is that
eventually this that cupboard is going
to run somewhat thin the revelations of
course really started with oprah we wait
to see how far it's got to go before the
royal family feel they have to respond
again and what reception the sussexes
receive when they return to the uk next
week rihanna mills sky news